you don't drink coffee no i don't trust
anybody who doesn't drink coffee
yeah this interview's over
my name is nick borrelli and i'm
traveling the country to sit down with
some of the biggest latinx artists in
places that are meaning to them and help
tell their stories this was probably the
place i grew most this whole movement is
to make sure that we do learn our
history
this is ballet folklorico my family was
under five different flags without ever
moving i'm ninth generation american i
never crossed a border the border
crossed us
when people go you know go home we are
this is home
the only way that you're going to break
through as a new show or a movie is
through innovation and the only way
innovation happens is by diversity and
so you can't keep going back to that
same talent pool because you're gonna
get the same movie
you're never too old to learn you're
never too old to
finish something or to go back and do
something i'm going to do this i can do
this i did it
you know
you